Coming into the home stretch,
like we're moving towards the constitution.
It's kind of amazing,
kind of weird.
Um,
and so as a matter of fact,
that's what we're going to be doing a with today's lecture,
um,
which is going to get us on the road to the federal convention.
I'm now just quick review before we plunged down the road.
I'm on Thursday,
uh,
as I hope you all remember,
I talked about some of the problems of the articles of confederation and I
talked about things that caused confusion or complications like boundaries
between states,
talked about Vermont,
talked about the state of Franklin,
um,
talked about Shay's rebellion towards the end of the lecture and throughout that
lecture from time to time I talked about some people who were strong advocates
for a stronger central government for the confederation.
And I mentioned a few names in passing.
I think I mentioned James Madison and I mentioned Alexander Hamilton and I
mentioned George Washington.
Obviously there are others.
Those are just three big name contenders.
There are others though.
At first we're not talking about a massive group of people here.
We're talking about a select group of people who really believe that there has
to be a stronger national government.
Now these men saw a host of problems with the articles of confederation.
I mentioned some of them on Thursday.
Um,
one of them you'll actually see a couple of times in the course of today's
lecture.
So these nationalists,
they saw problems with things like currency,
congressional indecision,
the fact that Congress was powerless to enforce things,
obviously boundary complications between states and a host of other problems
that at least to them signal the really obvious need for some kind of wide
ranging national political reform that would put more power at the center.
And for years and years and years,
these people kept calling for some kind of a national convention to reform the
government.
Now,
as I mentioned just a minute ago,
and I said it's sort of a select group.
Um,
it's important to note that this drive for a stronger national government was
not initially widespread.
And as a matter of fact,
there were any number of reasons for people really to fear the idea of
strengthening the national government.
And you're going to get a sense of some of these reasons next week when you look
at some of the federalist essays,
because part of what the federalist essays are doing is explaining and promoting
the new constitution,
or hopefully what will be the new constitution.
But the other thing that the federalist essays are doing is they're actually
trying to calm people's fears down.
Like,
okay,
you think that if you approve of this new constitution,
horrible things will happen,
but here's yet another way in which horrible things won't happen.
So you'll see that kind of as a running sub theme in the federalist essays too.
When you read them next week.
And as I suggested in the lecture,
I think on Thursday's lecture,
um,
obviously after he fought a revolution against what you perceive to be as a
tyrannical centralized power,
right?
The British monarchy,
it would make perfect sense in general to be a little worried about centralized
power.
Plus many people assumed that America was just bound to drift back into hid what
it had been before.
This fear goes actually even into the 1790s people assumed that because people
in America,
we're so used to one way of things.
It was a kind of a nifty little experiment they were undertaking now,
but as a matter of fact,
over time when push came to shove,
everything would sort of drift back to where it had been.
So the assumption is waiting out there in the wings somewhere,
there's an aristocracy it's going to leap up and take over as soon as they have
an opportunity and then suddenly poof,
we'll have an aristocracy and maybe a monarchy and everything will go back to
the way it was before.
So it makes sense that people were nervous about centralized power and it makes
sense that the states would be nervous too about centralized power because
they'd be nervous about giving up power to whatever this stronger centralized
government was going to be.
So what,
what today's lecture is going to do is look at how things evolved over the
course of just a few years.
So that by 1787,
which is where we're going to be on Thursday,
there actually was a call for a national convention to reform or amend the
government and then ultimately the new nation really did end up strengthening
the national government significantly,
which is all in all pretty remarkable.
When you think about some of what I've just been talking about,
it is pretty remarkable that there was that much change over in the end.
What isn't that huge expanse of time.
And as you'll see,
part of what's important to think about,
and I'll,
I'll mention it a couple times in the course of today's lecture,
um,
is the way in which America found its way into strengthening the government.
Because as you're going to see,
there's a series of individual events or individual meetings,
um,
none of them really focused on centralizing,
strengthening the central national government.
Although over time,
each one of these decisions as you're going to see today pushed things in that
direction.
So in a sense,
what you're going to see in today's lecture particularly is how the new nation
backed its way into a stronger central government.
One decision at a time.
They didn't leap into a new stronger government.
They backed their way in aided of course by some really strong nationalists in
the background trying to push things in that direction like Madison,
Hamilton,
Washington,
and the other crew of really from nationalists.
So basically that's kind of the sub theme or one of them,
at least of today's lecture.
It's how the new nation backed its way into a new,
stronger central government.
One decision at a time.
And in a sense it shouldn't be surprising that one of the main issues that
pushed this series of events into operation was commerce.
The question of commerce with 13 different states,
each with its own its own arrangements of commerce,
they were bound to be complications.
And obviously commerce is a big deal,
right?
Commerce matters,
commerce has prosperity,
commerce is livelihoods,
commerce is going to make or break individual states and make or break the new
nation.
If you think back to the revolution and think back to some of the things that
people were upset about,
again,
you're going to realize commerce is underlying a lot of what we're talking about
here,
right?
Rights are intermingled with these thoughts about commerce,
but we talked about taxation,
direct taxes,
imports,
exports,
shipping,
all of these kinds of things and more were among the many central components
that we're also helping to fuel the revolution.
So it shouldn't be a really big surprise that they continue to play a major role
in the development of the new nation.
And so what we're going to see in today's lecture is that the strong
nationalists pushing for a stronger national government would find that problems
of commerce,
sometimes open little doors of opportunity for political reform in ways that
might not have been expected.
Okay.
So that's what I want to do.
I want to sort of show the little process of reform or the process of change
over time and action.
And one major moment of opportunity that I'm going to start by talking about
here for these nationalists took place in 1785 because of a local complication
between Virginia and Maryland about navigating the Potomac river.
Okay.
So this is uh,
it's local and it also has to do with shipping.
Again,
more commerce.
So in response to this question,
v,
both Virginia and Maryland named commissioners to meet in Alexandria,
Virginia to discuss the issue and work out some kind of a policy.
So it doesn't seem necessarily like a really big deal.
There were a total of seven men named to be at this meeting.
There were three from Maryland,
there were four from Virginia,
including James Madison.
Unfortunately,
Virginia,
Governor Patrick Henry,
somehow or other managed to fumble something.
So he basically didn't tell the four Virginia delegates when the meeting was
happening and where the meeting was happening.
It's one of those administrative mistakes that you don't realize when you make
it,
it will be remembered forever.
Sorry,
Governor Henry.
But you goofed.
So the Virginia delegation is never told about where or when the meeting is.
The Maryland delegates arrive in Alexandria and find nobody waiting them.
Like where here and ultimately to Virginia delegates,
the ones who live closest to Alexandria managed to make their way there.
As soon as they found out they were supposed to be there,
Madison was not one of the people who ended up being there.
So now you have five people,
three from Maryland to from Virginia meeting in Alexandria and now they begin
talking about the problem and maybe entering into some kind of negotiations.
Now.
Meanwhile,
George Washington knew about this conference and given that Mount Vernon is not
that far away,
just down the road from the town of Alexandria,
he invited the commissioners out to mount Vernon to meet there.
Now Washington wasn't just being hospitable.
He actually had a really keen interest in having a canal built on the Potomac,
partly to promote its use and hopefully thus to make Alexandria and important
link to the West.
And that's the big center of shipping in the United States.
So Washington's thinking about promoting the importance of Alexandria through
doing something with the Potomac.
And he had been interested in this idea of building a canal for a while and he
had met with engineers and he had served in various committees and this was
really something that he felt very strongly about enough so that apparently
during a certain period of time,
anyone who went to visit him at Mount Vernon ended up just getting talked to
about canals.
Right?
You just knew in that phase of Washington's life,
if you visit him at Mount Vernon,
you're going to hear about canals,
so as one visitor to mount Vernon and put it at the time hearing little else for
two days,
I confess,
completely infected me with canal mania.
So Washington is suffering from canal mania too.
So he invites these commissioners to meet at his home at Mount Vernon,
knowing that are he can wine and dine them and hopefully encourage some kind of
compromise and maybe even promote the development of the Potomac.
The meeting at Mount Vernon was ultimately known as logically enough.
The Mount Vernon conference.
Surprise,
surprise.
It should be an easy one to remember.
The Mount Vernon conference.
It took place on March 25th,
1785 and continued for three days.
Mount Vernon conference March 25th,
1785 in the end,
the Malvern conference not only settled some matters of navigation,
but it also dealt with things like customs duties between the two states,
trade regulations between the two states and made recommendations about somehow
or other coordinating one states currency with the other states currency.
And the delegates also recommended that they meet annually to keep channels of
cooperation and communication open.
There's the key to not running conference,
let's meet annually to talk about this.
So although it wasn't intended to set any kind of a precedent,
that conference ends up being a step in the direction of some kind of regular
interstate cooperation apart from the Confederation Congress.
It's not just a local conference about the Potomac in two states.
Now it's proposing some kind of long term,
something in which two states get together and sort of figure out how to
cooperate amongst themselves.
And a little side note that actually won't really play a role in today's
lecture,
but it'll sort of echo something in Thursday's lecture.
Um,
in a sense,
the Mount Vernon conference ended up kind of violating Virginia's instructions
to its commissioners because the Virginia assembly and appointing the
commissioners had said,
okay,
so for you to approve of something,
three out of the four of you have to approve of it.
Right.
But only two guys actually showed up.
So even though the two guys were there and voted and things happened,
three out of four of them didn't vote on anything.
Right.
So officially,
formally speaking,
they weren't abiding by the mandate that they had gotten from their home state.
And I only mentioned this now because this will echo with some of the things
that happened in conjunction with the Federal Convention,
the Constitutional Convention on Thursday too.
Okay.
So let's pause here for a minute just to note how these people back their way
into this agreement.
Because the Malvern and conference didn't consist of five really ardent
nationalists just trying to find a sneaky way to do something that'll push
people towards being more organized in a centralized way.
The conference wasn't branded as anything other than a meeting for commissioners
from Maryland and Virginia to discuss navigation.
That led into a conversation about interstate trade that led into a decision to
maybe meet regularly and talk about this more broadly.
So in a sense,
what's begins this chain of events,
somewhat significant interstate agreement is kind of unintentional.
It's something really practical that gets it going.
We've seen this a lot in this course,
right?
It's something very practical that moves people to take action and then there
are really interesting outcomes from that response to something.
So I'm really practical need and as we'll see,
given all of the fears about centralized power,
in some ways it's this kind of informal indirect way of proceeding that's maybe
the best way for people to move towards centralizing or to move towards giving a
central government more power.
I'm going to see that again and again today.
Okay.
So it's informal,
it's indirect in a sense.
But the Mount Vernon conference did have the support of some eager nationalists.
So certainly James Madison was in favor of it even though he didn't make it,
but he was in favor of it.
Should have been there.
Um,
and of course George Washington is the host,
so yet another strong nationalist who is clearly in favor of it.
Both men certainly would've done their best to usher the agreement through the
Virginia legislature.
It also passed the Maryland legislature legislature as well.
Even more significant Maryland proposed bringing Delaware in the next time they
met inviting them to attend the next year's meeting.
And the commissioners themselves when they were at Mount Vernon,
they thought maybe they should invite Pennsylvania to,
okay.
So now we potentially have four states maybe agreeing to meet every year to talk
about interstate trade matters.
Now,
James Madison thinking nationally hoped that the Virginia legislature would
agree to submit this agreement to the Confederation Congress and then maybe all
of the states would agree to meet in this way every year.
And of course that I did,
it did not happen.
It failed.
Instead,
the Virginia legislature proposed a resolution that calls on the other states to
appoint delegates and to deliberately sit back and consider quote the trade of
the United States as a group and to propose some kind of an act regarding the
issue that could be sent to the Confederation Congress for passage.
So clearly I missed fears about centralized power at the time.
This is a pretty significant suggestion on the part of the Virginia legislature
and it's worth noting that even the mere suggestion of something like this had
to be helped along in its passage by some really careful strategy.
So although Madison really clearly wanted this,
this proposal to go through the legislature,
Madison is not the guy who proposed it because of Madison.
Mr Nationalists stood up and said,
hey,
I really think that we should all meet all the states together and consider the
trade of the United States.
Everyone would've said,
oh,
it's Mr Nationalists speaking.
I'm sorry we don't trust you.
So instead,
another man,
actually John Tyler,
who's the father of a future president,
Tyler,
um,
no,
he's not particularly known for his nationalist sentiments.
So his motors wouldn't be held suspect.
And he's the guy who actually makes this proposal.
So even just to recommend something along these lines,
people are being very strategic.
So ultimately there's a decision to hold a meeting about American trade,
a meaning that supposedly is going to include all of the states it's agreed to
by the Virginia legislature and it's scheduled to meet in Annapolis,
Maryland the next year,
September,
1786 okay.
So that's been going on in the south.
We have Virginia,
we have Maryland,
maybe Delaware and Pennsylvania,
but it's not as though none of,
none of this sort of activity or none of these fears had been happening in the
north.
And they had been also involving trade.
So at roughly the same time that all this is going on in the south,
the Massachusetts legislature ended up proposing their own resolution to think
more broadly about the national government.
Again,
spurred by trade complications,
basically northerners.
And then in particular merchants in Boston found themselves affected by British
trade restrictions in some ways that they really didn't like.
And they wanted the confederation Congress to do something about it.
And they also realize the Confederation Congress probably didn't have enough
power to do anything about it.
So the Massachusetts legislature,
thinking along these lines proposed something more broadly.
So instead of just saying,
well,
let's get together and talk about trade.
The Massachusetts state government asked the Massachusetts delegates in the
Confederation Congress to suggest calling a general convention of all of the
states to revise the articles of confederation as a whole.
Okay.
That's,
that's a big suggestion.
So the Massachusetts legislature basically asks,
it's delegates in the confederation Congress,
Hey,
would you,
here's a proposal for us to call some kind of meeting for all of the states,
just to revise the articles.
Would you present it to the Confederation Congress?
And the response of the three Massachusetts delegates in the Confederation
Congress is really interesting because it shows you why it's seemingly took
things happening outside of official channels like the Mount Vernon conference
for there to be broad interest date changes because basically in short,
the Massachusetts delegates responded by just refusing to submit the whole
proposal to the Confederation Congress and their,
their written response is really interesting.
I'm going to quote just a couple sentences from it here.
Um,
and this is what the delegates and the Confederation Congress responded to.
The people back in Massachusetts.
Many are of opinion.
The states have not yet had experienced sufficient to determine the extent of
powers vested in Congress by the Confederation and therefore that every measure
at this time proposing an alteration is premature.
The present confederation with all its inconveniences is preferable to the risk
of general dissensions and animosities,
which may approach to anarchy and prepare the way to a ruinous system of
government.
And what specifically did these guys think when they said general dissensions
and animosities will impart?
They met the following.
Again,
their words,
we are apprehensive and it is our duty to declare it.
That's such a measure.
Reforming the articles would produce throughout the union and exertion of the
friends of an aristocracy to send members who would promote a change of
government.
And we can form some judgment of the plan,
which such members would report to Congress.
Okay.
So essentially the Massachusetts delegates to the Confederation Congress say,
no,
we're not even going to consider this idea of revising the articles because it's
going to result in what they call baleful aristocracies,
right?
This is dangerous.
It's opening things up so that it's going to more centralized,
scary.
Aristocratic types are going to take over.
Bad things will happen.
Poof.
Spirit of the revolution all gone.
So here in 1785 we have Maryland,
we have Virginia,
we have Pennsylvania,
we have Delaware trying to do something,
centralizing about trade and Massachusetts also suggesting some pretty bold
reform because of problems with trade.
What was still pending at this time was the meeting that had been scheduled to
meet in Annapolis in September of 1786 now,
Madison for one was not overly optimistic about what everyone's going to happen
at Annapolis because he basically assumed he probably was smart to assume it.
As soon as you ask all of the states to agree to meet and decide anything,
it's not going to work,
right.
You're just bound to fail.
And indeed he gets to Annapolis and things just don't look too good.
As he wrote to his brother.
I came to this place a day or two ago where I found two commissioners,
only a few more have since come in.
But the prospect that was efficient number to make the meeting respectable is
not flattering.
And sure enough,
ultimately only five states sent delegates who arrived in time for the meeting.
Even Maryland,
the host state did not send delegates to the Annapolis Convention.
And that's a real snub out of fear that it transcended the power of the
Confederation Congress.
So the host state wasn't represented at the Annapolis Maryland Convention.
Three other states besides Maryland also chose not to send delegates,
South Carolina,
Georgia and Connecticut.
Yeah,
you can edit it all decided they would not send delegates and then delegates
from some of the states that were at the outer edges of the Union,
Massachusetts,
New Hampshire,
Rhode Island,
North Carolina.
Um,
they arrive too late to take partial,
all these people having these sort of weird administrative bad moments.
Sorry guys,
you didn't take place in the historic convention in Annapolis Cause you lift
home late or whatever it is they did.
They didn't plan well.
So all of those states are not represented at the Annapolis Convention,
but so they had all this fanfare,
all these nationalist or like,
wow,
we really need to meet about this.
They finally get a meeting.
It's scheduled for Annapolis and now it seems like nobody's going to attend.
So it's when Delaware delegate wrote to a friend,
should have of the states fail to participate.
Quote,
how ridiculous.
We'll all this parade appear.
So there they're getting ready in Annapolis to be mortified after all their
efforts.
Big Deal.
Like nobody cares.
Now before we see what actually transpired in the Annapolis Convention,
I want to have a little,
a little brief James Madison moment.
This is kind of a James Madison lecture and he's going to shine.
Um,
but I want to have a little moment for him here because as you're going to see
throughout the rest of this lecture and also on,
he does a number of really interesting things and ultimately some really
important things.
In 1786 in 1787 all of them in one way or another,
bound up with strengthening the government.
And I brought a very sophisticated visual aid.
There we go.
Okay.
So
this is James Madison.
I bring this James Madison because graduate student gave us to me years ago.
And what really amuses me about this,
I don't know if you could tell this is a GI Joe Buddy with a Madison head's
stuck on top.
You can't see really because of the lace covering his hands.
His,
he has like the Kung Fu grip thing going,
you know,
like he wants to be holding a gun.
So this is like buff James.
This is a macho Madison.
It is the weirdest looking thing with like this little tiny scholarly heads sort
of stuck on top.
This is,
this is my,
my high tech visual aid here.
We'll stick Madison over here.
He actually has a little stove.
What?
He's missing a shoe.
It's a little stand.
So Madison stand,
poor guy.
Just no respect.
He's not even getting respect now in the class,
during his moment he's shoeless.
Okay.
So he was given Madison some love.
Um,
I,
I do want to look at what Madison was doing in the month before the Annapolis
Convention because it's actually really interesting.
He does his twice.
He does this for two different summers.
Um,
he's thinks obviously thinking to himself,
okay,
I don't know what's coming down the road,
but there might be actual reform happening.
This is very exciting.
So I better prepare myself for the possibility of government reform.
So in this summer of 1786,
he basically does a little research project and he decides he's going to study
confederacy's of all time,
right?
He's going to look ancient times,
it's going to look modern times.
It's going to look at every confederacy that ever existed and then list in some
way their virtues and their vices.
So in essence,
Madison,
he's going to look over all time and then come up with these rules of
confederacy's,
right?
What works,
what doesn't.
And then hopefully once he figures that out,
somehow or other,
maybe it will help him in making suggestions to create or improve the present
one.
Now this is real.
This is like age of reason thinking,
this idea that if you can figure out the patterns of the past,
you can figure out the laws of nature and the way that things are supposed to
work.
And there's a,
there's a great example.
When I was in Grad School,
I guess,
um,
I read a book that at the time I thought was really fascinating,
which I guess means I'm destined to be a professor of early American history
because I'm the only one who finds it fascinating.
But I thought it was really fascinating.
Um,
it's actually by Adam Smith.
It's called the theory of moral sentiments.
And what amazed me about it was it's Adam Smith coming up with a sort of theory
for patterns of human emotion and morality.
So I mean,
that's again,
like age of reason,
thinking,
thinking Adam Smith is like,
okay,
I'm going to come up with a theory of moral sentiments and then presented to you
as to how morality works in human nature.
What I found really interesting about it was just if you're trying to figure out
the mindset of people in the 18th late 18th century,
that book is helpful.
I mean it may not present the all time tried and true theory,
but it is really interesting.
It says all kinds of sort of quirky,
interesting things in there that even if some people felt that way,
that's really interesting.
You don't really,
because another time period is really a different mindset.
So the Smith Book is kind of in the same spirit as Madison's efforts to study
all confederacy's and then come up with these amazing patterns.
So he's reading through book after book after book,
he's keeping record,
keeping little notes about various confederations and what he likes and what he
doesn't like and what worked and what didn't work.
Really,
really trying to figure out some kind of pattern that's going to help the United
States.
And supposedly he recorded his notes in a little like a little notebook that was
about 40 pages long that maybe he intended to have with him during debate.
Maybe he intended to have it with him as a sort of writing reference.
I love just the whole system and operation of this.
Right.
I will figure it all out and then it will carry it in my pocket.
My knowledge about all confederacy's over time.
Little let me look in.
Yeah,
so this is very Madison,
very typical Madison and actually little bits of that end up appearing in the
federalist essay.
So if he was thinking it was going to be a help in his writing,
he was right.
He actually does draw on it and so he looks at all these confederacy's and so
it's not a big surprise.
What is Madison discover?
Well,
basically everywhere he looks,
he's fines,
jealousies,
and animosities between member states of whatever confederacy we're talking
about.
He sees domestic turmoil,
he sees international humiliation.
He sees basically week unions are a problem unions.
That's,
that's the lesson he draws from his little survey.
So this is on his mind,
right?
He does this little studying project and then he heads out to Annapolis to join
the convention in September of 1786 only five states represented New York,
New Jersey,
Pennsylvania,
Delaware,
and Virginia.
I guess I'll repeat that for you.
In New York,
New Jersey,
Pennsylvania,
Delaware and Virginia.
Um,
a total of 12 delegates.
So we're not talking about massive numbers of people here.
Um,
and logically enough,
he get the 12 guys there from the five states and the first thing they do is
they compare what their home states told them to do.
Okay.
Why did your states and you here,
why did your seats,
when you hear like is there actually anything that we have in common?
What they discovered was it four of the five states had instructions from their
home states confining their attention to just matters of trade.
Right.
Okay.
Go to Annapolis and talk about trade period.
But we're going to have a New Jersey moment.
Is there,
there are New Jersey people.
Oh,
we got New Jersey people.
Yes.
Okay.
It's a New Jersey is shining New Jersey moment.
So four of the five,
it just says,
Joe's considered trade New Jersey.
New Jersey has three magical words in their instructions from home and the New
Jersey instructions say,
yeah,
go ahead.
Consider trade and quote other important matters.
Okay.
That's the only opening they needed.
It's like,
Oh,
other important matters.
And that case we can think more broadly than trade,
right?
So New Jersey has the little tiny key that lets these people meeting in
Annapolis at least think about moving beyond just talking about trade.
They talk for three days about whether they should really proceed along any line
because of the magical three words and then a jersey instructions.
They finally decide that yes,
they will take advantage of that little opening to talk about other important
matters.
So they prepared and address to their own state,
to,
to all the other states that had decided not to come or that hadn't made it on
time,
that are rushing somewhere from North Carolina.
Um,
and the address was prepared by Alexander Hamilton,
obviously yet another one of these strong nationalists.
He's trying,
I think as early as 1780 we needed a stronger government.
So Hamilton's address,
ask the states to name delegates to meet in Philadelphia the following year to
quote,
take into consideration the situation of the United States to device such
further provisions as shall appear to them necessary to render the constitution
of the federal government adequate to the exit exigencies of the Union.
Okay,
so basically we need to meet and just think more broadly about the government is
what Hamilton's proposal says.
Now again,
look at how almost accidental what we're looking at here is right this
significant proposal to alter the articles with only a handful of men present at
Annapolis.
This suggestion almost is more a matter of desperation like,
well we have to come out of this with something thanks to New Jersey,
we can do something.
So here let's make the proposal and send it out and see what happens.
And this bold move is grounded on three words in the New Jersey instructions.
Again,
it's all of these sort of out of formal channels or informal ways in which
people are promoting some kind of more centralizing agenda.
So once the move is taken,
they send this out,
the address is sent out.
Nationalists like Hamilton and Madison and others throughout the states take
full advantage of it and really push so that something will come of this.
There'll be some kind of an attempt to actually strengthen the national
government in eight states,
nationalists managed to get their state legislatures to pass resolutions
suggesting precisely the kind of broad agenda for a that the Annapolis people
wanted.
So eight states are like,
yeah,
okay,
we could get behind a conference to reconsider the government,
which brings us to Shay's rebellion momentarily because in a really handy stroke
of timing,
Shay's rebellion happens right in the middle of what we're talking about right
now.
Right?
So they're like,
well,
let's push to try and make the government stronger.
Oh,
Shay's rebellion.
Right?
So the nationalists are like,
we hate this,
but yes,
it's like,
this is really bad.
But wow,
is this a handy PR tool?
Because now they can point to Shay's rebellion and say,
look,
we're collapsing into chaos.
Wow.
Do we need a stronger national government?
So the timing of it,
if you're a guy who really wants a stronger national government in this period
was a good stroke of fortune.
So again,
as we're looking at ultimately what's going to become the constitutional
convention or the Federal Convention,
you can see here some of the pat,
the problems of having a central government with such diffuse powers.
Because even now someone says,
well,
let's strengthen the government.
And then Congress takes a long time to think about the possibility of
strengthening the government.
Surprise,
surprise.
So the committee is appointed to consider this idea in October of 1786 and in
February of 1787 the committee finally issues a report and the report says,
wow,
revising the articles maybe,
right?
None of this.
Like let's review everything.
Revising the articles.
Okay,
maybe we can go along with that.
And the states should name delegates to attend a conference,
to just improve the articles,
not to just evaluate the needs of the union.
So for states ultimately follow that formula,
right?
They say,
okay,
only revise other states.
Follow the Annapolis Annapolis formula and say,
well,
okay,
let's actually reconsider the government.
So the meaning of Philadelphia,
what ends up being in the constitutional convention starts out with a confused,
contradictory mandate because there's no general agreement about number one,
what the meaning is really supposed to accomplish.
And number two,
how it's even supposed to be planned.
So eight states get the call from Annapolis and respond.
The other states are a number of the other states.
Wait until the confederation Congress says something and then they respond to
the confederation Congress instead.
So I radically in a meeting that's supposed to repair shortcomings of the
Confederation Congress,
that meeting itself as being complicated by shortcomings of the Confederation
Congress.
You can,
you can see how it's very hard to do anything in a really national manner with
all of the states.
So obviously the nationals are really hoping things are going to follow the
Annapolis formula as Washington,
put it,
revising the,
not just revising the articles,
but probing the defects of the constitution to the bottom and providing radical
cures.
So that's what the nationalists want.
Um,
as we're going to see on Thursday,
strong nationalists were really active in the months before the convention
planning.
And preparing to push forward their agenda.
And here we have James Madison,
James Madison,
she was James Madison,
where to shoe go.
She loves to use that as a moment number two,
but we'll see.
I guess it makes professors happy because he's like studying all by himself.
Like I'll do a summer study project,
but he's a scholarly founders scholar's life,
James Madison.
Um,
so scholarly project number two,
he decides it now just like before he was looking for virtues and vices of
confederacy's over time.
Now he's going to look at vices in the American confederacy and he actually
titles this document vices of the political system of the EU states or the
United States.
So he again comes up with a list of vices,
problems in the American system and he lists things like states trespassing on
each other's rights,
like a lack of unity between states,
even when unity is desperately required,
like the fact that states can encroach on federal authority without any
repercussions.
States violate treaties and again,
who's going to do anything about it.
So he's making a list of all these devices and some of them again ultimately
ended up being talked about in the essays that he contributes to the federalist.
So Madison basically it has this long term study project in preparation for what
comes to be known as the constitutional convention.
As we'll talk about on Thursday,
he also arrives in addition to all of us studying with a draft plan of
government.
So in case he hasn't done enough now I will arrive with the draft plan of
Um,
and we will talk more about what his plan suggest for an entirely new
constitution on Thursday.
I'm in the,
the last bit of the course of the today's class.
I want to mention one other thing.
I think just cause I don't think I'm going to have time to talk about it on
Thursday,
but I don't want to go without mentioning it because it's yet another one of
this sort of weird,
interesting things at Madison does associated with the constitutional
convention.
And it'll have more meaning after Thursday's lecture.
But I'll mention it now.
Um,
and some of you may already know this because you may have used this in papers
or things for classes,
but Madison took notes and he didn't just take notes.
I mean,
he really took notes.
He noted almost all of the proceedings of the convention,
of all of the delegates.
He ended up taking the most careful,
the most consistent,
not quite minute by minute,
not quite comprehensive,
but really thorough notes of what went on at that convention of what people
said,
of how they argued about what they argued about,
about what was done.
And he has notes are really amazing.
They're published,
they're easy to find there.
Even on the Internet.
Um,
the library of Congress has,
I think they're called foreigns notes of debate or something.
Um,
but there you can see Madison's notes,
you can read Madison's notes.
He actually invented some kind of a little shorthand.
So during the day with a little shorthand,
he was copying down everything that people said.
And then at night he was transposing that back into real writing.
And again,
this was like his project of the constitutional convention and his notes,
I mean they're published and they're easy to find,
but the fact is his actual notes are at the library of Congress and you're a
million a million years ago.
I'm not going to say how many years ago,
many years ago.
Um,
I worked at the library of Congress,
um,
and I worked on exhibits at the Library of Congress,
you know,
like museum exhibits curating them.
And the library of Congress is an amazing place to do that because you know,
how much fun is it to be able to pick stuff from the library of Congress to put
in exhibits.
They have everything,
they have amazing stuff.
They have the contents of Abraham Lincoln's pockets on the night he died,
you know,
they have like drafts of the Gettysburg address and the declaration of
independence.
It's just amazing,
amazing stuff.
I remember one exhibit I worked on on the bicentennial of Congress,
we have like a little room where we were stacking stuff for the exhibit and it
was like,
Whoa,
let's a space instruments from the first voyage and just space.
And a draft of the Gettysburg address and here's what you was like,
aw.
Like waves of history emanating out of the room.
So,
so they have Madison's notes there and the library,
I don't know if at the same thing exists now,
but I know that a million years ago when I worked at the library,
um,
they have like the top treasures,
I think it was the top 12 treasures of the library of Congress and they kept
them in a vault and it was like,
um,
like Gutenberg Bible,
Madison's notes,
uh,
Jefferson's draft of the declaration.
Um,
what else?
George Mason's Virginia Declaration of Rights.
I'm just like,
oh,
sort of objects in this vault,
in the library of Congress.
And supposedly when these items come out of the vault,
they're supposed to be accompanied by an armed guard.
Okay.
Which I thought it was like a rule,
but like,
Haha,
shore,
you know,
armed guard.
Like,
okay,
high security.
But Lo and behold,
when I wanted to get some of George Mason's notes to put in the exhibit,
there was a guy with a gun walking next to me.
I was like George Mason Predicting George Mason from,
I don't know who gonna come running down the hall,
the Library of Congress.
But anyway,
they really meant it with the armed guard.
But,
but so far for that same exhibit,
I got to look through Madison's notes.
I got to pick a page from Madison's notes to put in the exhibit.
And it's just amazing to see them because,
okay,
there are the notes from the moment.
So there's the guy,
you know,
basically recording how the constitution is being created.
And Madison,
um,
it's I to say something,
which this doesn't illustrate.
He's actually a little guy.
He's not GI Joe.
Um,
he,
he's a small man,
you know,
he quiet man,
sort of bookish kind of a guy.
So he has this little tiny bookish,
perfect meticulous handwriting.
Like his handwriting looks just like you think James Madison's handwriting ought
to be.
You know,
you look at it and you're like,
that must be James Madison.
Um,
and so there,
there's like this box of these little slips of paper with these little
meticulous Madison notes of what he saw at the Federal Convention for some
magical reason.
I think it was long enough ago that nobody will get fired by my saying is there
was like no guard.
They just like left me with a box.
So I was sort of like,
oh,
you know,
Madison's notes.
This is so exciting.
It's like,
yeah,
I think it'll take me an hour to find a page so that I can weave through and see
everything that's kind of an amazing artifact.
Um,
and the fact of matter is,
you know,
Madison was doing that for a very specific reason.
I mean,
Madison,
this whole generation tends to think about posterity.
I'll talk about that a little bit in the last lecture as well.
But they're,
they're very posterity minded.
So part of the reason why Madison goes through all of this trouble to record
what's going on at the convention,
although I think he actually doesn't record jokes.
I think some other people's notes now that I'm thinking about it,
some other people's notes.
Yes,
it Madison did nothing.
Constitution making was funny.
There'll be no jokes and Madison's notes,
they're pretty sad jokes.
I mean,
18th century jokes often are not like,
ha ha.
You know,
it's like,
it's kind of sad.
There's a,
there's a,
um,
there's a book called something like George Washington laughing,
but it's George Washington laughing at other people's jokes because I guess he
didn't tell them anyway.
So I think Madison expunge the humor out of the whole situation,
but,
but he's thinking about posterity,
not necessarily by taking out the jokes,
but he's really thinking about the fact that somewhere down the road,
if this actually works at this constitution actually survives and actually
functions,
it's going to be this amazing thing.
It's going to be a room of people that like deliberated and thought about
government and then created it based on deliberating in a really purposeful way,
which almost never happens when you're creating a government.
And then they created what Madison hoped would be a fair,
just small r Republican government.
So He's thinking,
well,
if I take all of these notes and I record this whole process down,
it's almost like a little guide book to future countries that might want to make
Republican governments.
Like,
here's how we did it.
And that was the idea behind what he was doing was he really did want to
preserve the process.
And that's pretty much what he did with his notes.
So those of you who are interested,
again,
they're kind of easy to find.
They're all over the place.
Um,
F A.
R,
r a,
n,
d Max Faron I think is the most famous version of them,
but they're very easy to find.
Um,
I think I will end there.
I will not move on to talk about Madison's plan.
I will talk about the plan and the constitution on Thursday.
Those of you who had not yet handed in papers should be handing in papers and I
will see you on Thursday.